hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
you read that title right we're gonna be
talking about a new event called the
blades of Persia it's been like a couple
weeks since the other event just ended
so right back to another event which is
fantastic so as long as like to be if
you do in July subscriber for new I
covered the informational side I've
honored that being the balance changes
to hear updates the patch notes and the
leaks every wonder he kept it today with
everything happening within the world or
on earth and ever miss out and update
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
and with that let's get started with
today's video real quick though before
we start I do want to thank you be
software providing me the early access
to be able to record an upload this
video as early as it is it's like a half
an hour into the dev shoot so we're
super super early on getting this video
out so thing guys forget providing me
with that early access but yes you read
the title right it is a new events
called the blades of Persia it's a
crossover event between Prince of Persia
and for honor and if you didn't know
that Ubisoft way back when in like 2010
or 2008 made the Prince of Persia game
to the sands of time and all that stuff
so they have the rights to it which is
why there's a crossover event and we
have a lot of stuff to go over in this
event so let's get straight to it this
event is gonna be two chapters long the
first chapter is March 12th the day that
you're seeing this and the second
chapter starts next week on March 19th
there's gonna be a game-mode that's
going to be changing in week one and
week two very similar to the honor games
but we don't know anything about the
week two game modes so we have to cover
that in next week's video but we'll get
to the game mode at just one second
obviously we have to go over the other
stuff and the general music and theme of
course is very sandy stuff everywhere
you could tell on the main menu there's
the big boy Prince in front with his
signature dagger as well some nice sand
and the background the map is also
drenched in sand as well with a giant
sandstorm near the volcano on the
faction map the music on the overall
main menu in face off screen is great as
well so definitely take a listen to that
I got some nice soothing music on the
main menu to kind of ease you into the
event with some more epic sounds than
the face off screen and speaking of that
screen it is covered in sand that's
gonna be a [ __ ] to get out but of
course because it's an event it comes
with new content so we're gonna be
getting to illustrious outfits sand
rates servant and ratash azar me both
references to bosses slash enemies of
the Prince of Persia games and this of
course comes in Idol
emotes and execution
there's also going to be a separate
execution called blade of fate for all
heroes this will be costing ten thousand
steel and the execution is the same for
every hero so no faction based
executions this time but it's still a
cool execution nonetheless and
definitely going to put this on my
characters
this is also the introduction of
something we haven't had before a free
pass this is very similar to the current
seasonal pass that we have except it's
it's own thing and it's free and you can
pay tears with steel if you choose to in
terms of the event content it replaces
the end of match loot meaning players do
not have to rely on luck to get the
cosmetic rewards and they will have full
visibility on what they will be able to
earn when they get them this event pass
is going to be 30 tiers long as opposed
to the regular games 100 it will be free
as I stated and you can use steel to
progress faster and every rank in the
event pass or every rank in the battle
pass is parallel to the other they're
both 300 battle points per tier so one
tier in battle pass is won in the event
and one in the event is 1/2 the battle
pass and in terms of purchasing those
tiers you can also purchase them and
they will count for both so if you end
up buying ten tiers it will give you ten
in the event pass and ten in the battle
pass among other stuff the concept for
this includes the sub ulis time mood
effect calinas discipline battle often a
reference to the character Kalina from
the game and the hourglass of Perga
which is based around the hourglass of
time from the game as well on top of
that there's also some new lootable
weapons I'll be covering the event pass
and the weapons in a separate video
about five minutes from when this is
going live so right after this video you
can go to that one so real quick to
recap everything that we have been
talking about in this current section we
have the mood effect the battle outfit
and the ornaments which will be in the
past weapons the new 10k execution and
the two illustrious outfits and raids
servant Emre Tasha's army will not be in
the past weapons must be grinded as
usual so if you play a Highland yoga
Highlander weapons and you won't get any
other character so definitely pick the
character for the weapons you want and
the execution must be bought for 10000
steel and of course the illustrious
outfits need to be bought separately as
well there's also an arcade quest for
this as well so no worries for all you
arcade players but lastly we have to
talk about the game mode and everything
that comes with it but before we start I
want to get a little bit deep with you
boys so real quick all of us understand
what cancer is and its devastating
effects on families throughout the world
but some people seem to be leaving out a
very important form of that cancer
pancreatic the survival rate without
funding is atrocious you literally have
more chance of surviving the lethal
injection than you do this and I think
that's pretty pathetic so first there
will be a link down in the description
to donate to the foundation to help
support more research and every stream I
do whether it be YouTube or twitch
throughout March will have a link to
this foundation as well it's going to be
at some incentives on stream so that
people can give you know that reasoning
to donate but we'll be getting to that
later when I actually do start to stream
but don't you worry though I'm not alone
others like daddy law lolli tool clutch
Meister Nord setback Kenzo toxic splice
J karela havoc odds Darva zero Craig and
many more are helping out as well so I'm
not alone
expect a lot more streams this month and
please donate to help the families
affected by this thank you so
essentially it's a regular Dominion
match on harbor with a little bit of a
twist it's called the ruler of time and
basically one a minute into the game the
prince spawns he's essentially 80 on D
with four crazy new feats feat one
allows him to teleport to anyone like
Shaolin and do a devastating punch when
he arrives to the target and if landed
and knocks out your entire stamina bar
and you fall on the ground feet to is
like warlords forth to your feet where
he responds with half health he pretty
much ends up technically dying and then
disappearing and reappearing again with
half health and feet four is an overkill
Highlander era storm essentially there's
almost no time to escape this attack
I've been hit by this every single time
and have died every single time so
definitely keep a watch out on this and
from spawn he gets this from the start
so watch out but of course because it's
a feat there's going to be cooldown so
he won't be spamming these as often but
upon death whatever team happens to kill
him gets 150 hard points meaning that
they will never disappear just like soft
points are considered capture points
these are considered hard points and
those 150 points will never disappear
but don't get too comfortable because
within a minute of defeating him he will
just be come right back and he's gonna
be looking for revenge
he's also super easy to spot so you're
never gonna be caught off guard with the
giant health bar and the announcement at
the top and the huge sandstorm that
appears in the map
top of that the minions have been
changed they seem to have turned into
what I believe is the sand rates from
the game but I could be wrong as well
the Knights would it seems like to be
are these blue kind of skeleton decrepit
characters looks really really cool
whereas the Vikings are kind of the
opposite and they're these fat kind of
undead creatures so definitely one of my
favorite minion changes to date easily
in the top three only being rivaled by
the Halloween skeletons and the Raving
Rabbids in terms of the map itself it's
obvious how sandy everything is there's
loads of new structures and buildings in
the background towards the more City
side of the harbour the water is gone as
well and now replaced with sand
especially near the attack spawn they
seem to be spikes in the water to stop
incoming ships but thanks to the sand it
all washes ashore and this goes really
really far like I traveled insanely far
in the middle of the map you're going to
see this bright kind of light that's the
fire on screen I believe a capture point
a so kudos to Ubisoft for extending this
extremely extremely far obviously past a
certain point there's really nothing
because we can't see that far so you'll
see the occasional ship back here but
it's pretty much just sand the farther
you go out but staying more grounded on
the inside of the map there is a new
lethal but also non-lethal traps
lethal in the sense that it does damage
but non-lethal in the sense that it's
only about a bar there's some new saws
on a point which is very similar to that
Viking village kind of map it's not the
actual Viking village but you understand
what I'm talking about if you've played
duels and elimination and such there's
that giant saw on the one Viking map
that also kind of looks like a harbour
well there's going to be saws on this
point as well and then periodically
throughout the other areas like C and a
there's going to be spikes everywhere
near the capture points that are on a
timer and they just pop up when the
sparks fly so definitely be careful
they'll come up then they'll go back
down you'll see some sparks and then
they'll come up and go back down and
they just keep going there is no
specific pressure plate that you have to
touch for it to pop off it just goes
whenever it wants to and yeah that's
pretty much the whole event the blades
of Persia so like I said next video is
going to be coming out in probably five
to ten minutes from now and that's gonna
be with the event pass with all thirty
tiers so you could see what you're gonna
be getting when you hop on and then of
course the weapons which I didn't show
and this because I want it to save it
for the next video so that's going to be
coming out probably five to ten minutes
by the time you finished this video it
should already be out if you've watched
the whole thing from the start so
definitely go check that out immediately
after this video is over but as always
guys like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe for a new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
want to be kept up today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out when an update that
please they subscribe the channel that
guys take care I'll see you about five
ten minutes for that second video and
then if you've already watched that I'll
see you for next week for Chapter two
and we get to see what changes in the
new event take care guys
peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]